panneaux photovoltaïques pompes à
chaleur cette maison en ossature bois
situé à magny les hameaux et lauréate
d'un concours organisé en 2014 par l'
agence locale de l'énergie et du climat
de saint quentin en yvelines
sa particularité elle est économe l'idée
c'est vraiment de de consommer le moins
d'énergie et en plus ils produisent de
l'énergie grâce aux panneaux solaires
photovoltaïques une production
énergétique qui permet aux propriétaires
de payer leur facture annuelle
d'électricité depuis 30 ans ils ont
multiplié les aménagements pour rénover
leur habitat isolation changement des
fenêtres et installation d'une pompe à
chaleur il y a trois ans montant des
travaux
80000 euros un investissement qui permet
avant tout d'améliorer leur confort où
on a fait ça pourra pour vraiment un
comment en termes de d'économies mais
surtout un confort de chauffe qui est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus intéressant
que les chauffages électriques
traditionnels une maison que les
particuliers ont pu découvrir à
l'occasion du premier salon de la
rénovation énergétique objectifs de
l'événement découvrir tous les acteurs
du secteur présents sur notre territoire
c'est important pour mettre concrètement
des visages derrière des métiers et puis
découvrir un petit peu ce que c'est
puisque l'idée aussi de la plateforme
c2c de rassembler tous les acteurs de la
rénovation énergétique et dans les
acteurs il ya autant ceux qui font les
travaux que les maîtres d'ouvragé en
2017 sur le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines 90 propriétaire à faibles
ressources ont reçu une aide pour
rénover leur habitat